on va parler de la présidentielle et de
notre baromètre mensuel au doxa pour les
chaînes parlementaires et la presse
régionale et ce mois-ci alex et bien ce
baromètre de donner des la perception
des manuels macron dans l'opinion avant
qu'il ne rentre officiellement en
campagne y ont rien on va commencer par
une question simple d'entrée qui est
posée dans ce baromètre diriez-vous
qu'emmanuel macron est un bon président
de la république eh bien la réponse est
non à 57 % des suffrages des personnes
interrogées oui pour 41% d'entre eux
même si emmanuel macron est un petit peu
plus populaire que le mois dernier une
petite progression de 2 2% l'autre
question qui découle logiquement c'est
souhaitez-vous qui emmanuel macron se
présente à l'élection présidentielle et
bien c'est un oui à
45% mais il y a un an il y avait
seulement un tiers des français qui
souhaitaient que le président de la
république se représente donc là aussi
il y à une progression et là où c'est
intéressant et bien c'est quand on
analyse cette donnée au regard des
sympathies des affinités politiques des
personnes interrogées alors tous les
sympathisants de la république en marche
veulent que le président se représente
ça c'est assez logique seulement 12%
pour les sympathisants du rassemblement
national mais entre les deux et bien il
y a environ la moitié des sympathisants
europe ecologie les verts parti
socialiste et les républicains qui
souhaite qu emmanuel macron se
représente à l'élection présidentielle
donc qui ne le lui qui ne lui sont pas
complètement hostile et on attend avec
impatience la déclaration de candidature
d'emmanuel mâcon les français oui non et
les français aussi 71% des français
estiment qu emmanuel macron doit
déclarer sa candidature maintenant car
selon eux est bien la campagne
présidentielle a déjà commencé ce n'est
donc pas juste une obsession
journalistique comme le laisserait
penser certains responsables de la
majorité présidentielle il ya une vraie
attente des français pour qu emmanuel
macron descendre dans l'arène et puis
pour affiner cette perception du
président de la république dans
l'opinion avant sa déclaration de
candidature est bien regardons comment
les français jugent son action dans
certains domaines 42% jugent son action
positive sur la sécurité la lutte contre
le terrorisme même ratio pour sa
politique contre le chômage 38 % des
français sont satisfaits de sa politique
en matière de santé et ce après 2 temps
de crise sanitaire et puis un score plus
bas en revanche sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat seulement 25 % des
français jugent son action positive dans
ce domaine alors que le pouvoir d'achat
est une préoccupation très forte dans
ces camps dans cette campagne
présidentielle avec ce contexte de
hausse des prix et on va revenir sur ses
enseignements et d'abord la déclaration
de candidature qui est donc attendue par
les français plus de soixante dix pour
cent disent qu'il doit se déclarer mais
seulement 45% soit il se représente
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle ça pour
emmanuel macron non c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle
malgré tout le chef de l'état reste le
favori pour l'instant de cette élection
présidentielle avec un socle électoral
qui est plutôt solide 2017 au premier
tour il recueille 24 % des voix
aujourd'hui il est autour de 25 % dans
les sondages donc il a conservé son
étiage de 2017 ce qui est plutôt bon
signe et son avance sur les autres
candidats restent relativement forte
puisqu'il a voilà quasiment dix points
d'écart avec valérie pécresse ou marine
le pen qui sont derrière donc pour lui
c'est quand même une position qui est
assez confortable il l'a dit il veut
présider jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure
il ne faut pas pour autant qu'ils
s'enferment dans ce slogan est dans
cette consigne là parce qu'on voit bien
que après avoir retardé parce qu'il y
avait la présidence française de l'union
européenne parce qu'il y avait la
reprise de la crise sanitaire avec au
micron et maintenant les tensions avec
l'ukraine
dans quelques jours c'est ce sujet là ne
sera pas réglé donc pour lui maintenant
ça va être la difficulté de trouver la
bonne fenêtre de tir est aussi
certainement d'adapter son discours
parce que ce n'est pas la même chose
d'entrée en campagne sur des bonnes
nouvelles effectivement sur le par
exemple chômage dont il peut se targuer
qu'avec un fond de l'air une menace
d'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
voilà ça change quand même
considérablement la donne pour lui du
coup ils se retrouvent un peu piégé
emmanuel mâcon pour vos pierre jacqmin
avoir voulu attendre effectivement la
présidence française la crise sanitaire
la crise en ukraine maintenant que la
crise en ukraine
et s'aggrave et qui se retrouvent
piégées par tarder à annoncer sa
candidature d'une certaine manière il
s'est piégé lui-même parce
qu'effectivement il a annoncé un
calendrier
en expliquant qu'il ne pouvait pas se
prétendre vous savez que la reka au
candidat parce que il y avait le
contexte de la crise sanitaire parce
qu'il y avait le contexte de la crise
russo ukrainienne donc oui c'est piéger
et en même temps pour récemment les
lardons très mal chronique
je suis pas sûr que ça le déstabilise ça
pourrait presque même la rangée
finalement parce que plus tard il va
rentrer en campagne mieux ce sera pour
lui parce que plus tôt il rentre en
campagne plus il sera l'objet d'
attaques de ses concurrents directs plus
tôt il rentre en campagne plus il sera
amené à faire son propre bilan aussi
assumer son propre bilan et c'est là où
aujourd'hui effectivement depuis
plusieurs mois s'il est assez stable et
très haut dans les sondages c'est aussi
parce qu'il est en situation de
gouverner le pays aussi parce qu'il est
en situation où il se met en scène on
l'a dit ici dans cette émission
plusieurs fois on l'a suivi en creuse
dans le nord il va avec ses petits bras
règle les problèmes de la crise russo
ukrainienne et dont qui montre un
président en exercice qui ne se soucie
pas des guerres et autant vous direz
vous voyez tous les jours que les
guerres en ce moment que ce soit à
gauche à droite les coups bas les les
propos les plus extrêmes chaque jour il
se maintient hors de ce contexte
politique est assez nauséabond et saluer
plutôt profitable donc je pense que plus
tard il rentre en campagne mais ce sera
en revanche il ya quand même une date
butoir qui est celle du dépôt des
candidatures en tout cas tu es de la
réception du nombre de parrainages
suffisants ce qui est pas son problème
et pour lui puisqu'il a déjà obtenu le
nombre de parrainages suffisants auprès
du conseil constitutionnel
mais il ya quand même un moment donné où
le jeu démocratique veut que il annonce
officiellement sa candidature oui à un
moment il va être obligé d'y aller mais
effectivement à cet argument des
dossiers chauds sur le feu sur son
bureau pour le président de la
république mais en réalité ils regardent
aussi beaucoup les sondages et donc oui
il est seul en tête devant au premier
tour dans ces études d'intentions de
vote et d'ailleurs des sondages qui sont
en train de dessiner à cette campagne
présidentielle avec un président qui est
seul devant donc il n'a pas besoin pour
l'instant de se déclarer assez tôt une
petite compétition à droite pour aller
au second tour une petite compétition à
gauche pour montrer qu'on existe encore
et puis si on regarde et bien un petit
peu avec le recul par exemple il ya dix
ans l'élection où nicolas sarkozy devait
se représenter eh bien pour un second
mandat et bien lui s'était présenté un
petit peu plus tôt mi février car
justement dans les sondages il était
déjà distancée par françois hollande et
donc ils avaient besoin de rattraper son
retard et au final il ne l'a pas fait et
avec le recul il aurait estimé qu' il
aurait fait mieux de se présenter plus
tôt ouais ça peut être henry ça pour
emmanuel macron de se présenter trop
tard bien sûr parce que si on se
présente tard dans l'élection c'est
d'autant moins de temps pour installer
des propositions ou des thématiques sur
lesquelles ils aimeraient engager de
nouvelles dynamiques ce que vous
montriez dans vos dans vos enquêtes et
dans vos chiffres c'est qu'il ya quand
même une majorité de français qui a
l'air de vouloir chercher une
alternative ou en tout cas il ya
toujours cette contestation est bien sûr
le président ne fait pas l'unanimité il
ya aussi un rejet qui existe dans
l'opinion mais pour l'instant
ces électeurs là n'ont pas trouvé
forcément de candidats de candidature
qui puisse faire office d'alternative à
emmanuel macron pour lui ça peut être un
risque effectivement ce que dans les six
semaines à venir il y à une forte
dynamique qui qui qui émergent même si
ça pour l'instant ça n'en prend pas le
chemin et surtout avec cette crise
diplomatique cette crise avec avec
l'ukraine on voit bien que ça a une
incidence sur l'élection présidentielle
pas seulement sur sur l'agenda du
président mais parce que ça va devenir
un sujet de la campagne
on le voit yannick jadot a d'ailleurs
déjà réagi hier soir par un communiqué
en demandant des fortes sanctions
notamment contre les oligarques russes
il va y avoir des râles semblant ça va
changer cette campagne présidentielle
considérablement pas beaucoup joué sur
l'international du coût de cette
campagne pour vos plats oui sans doute
que cette crise
va jouer et surtout va faire exacerber
un certain nombre de tensions y compris
le clivage au sein de la classe
politique maintenant
je pense que pour revenir sur le
calendrier des de l'arrivée en campagne
diminue de macron ce qui est important
c'est que il n'aura pas le droit à
l'erreur quand il va rentrer en
accompagnement du mâcon parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des candidats
sont partis très tôt pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ils ont fait des erreurs
mais ils ont pu se rattraper et s'il
maniema qu'on rentre en campagne en
faisant une erreur en se faisant en
prenant par exemple l'action qui est la
sienne dans la résolution du conflit ou
en tout cas en essayant de tenter
d'aider des actions diplomatiques avec
la russie l'ukraine les états unis d'un
autre côté et l'union européenne s'il
fait des erreurs ça va être compliqué
pour lui parce qu'il risque de chuter
très vite ça risque de lui être très
désagréable à ce moment là donc c'est le
risque qu'il prend est rentré très tard
en campagne pour revenir sur la question
sur l'international oui on voit
qu'aujourd'hui que ce soit les questions
climatiques que ce soit les questions
géostratégiques géopolitique les
questions numériques c'est un enjeu
absolument important et il faut espérer
qu effectivement ça en devienne un sujet
politique de premier plan dans cette
élection présidentielle est ce que le
fait de tarbes et y'a pas aussi un
risque pour le chef de l'état c'est de
faire campagne finalement sur son bilan
est ce qu'on a le temps en un mois de
faire émerger des propositions pour la
suite du quinquennat est ce que ça a le
temps d'imprimer dans l'esprit des
français et ça c'est moins sûr
j'entendais votre invité tout à l'heure
aux lilas grégoire nous expliquer que si
le président lui-même n'est pas en
campagne bon ça remet en doute un peu
parce qu'on imagine bien quand même
qu'il vient tout type en campagne quand
ils baladent à droite à gauche y compris
en europe et ailleurs ces équipes la
cité edouard philippe richard ferrand je
sais petit stéphane guérini stanislas
pardon irini était hier en réunion
au qg de marche pour travailler pour
réfléchir on voit bien qu'il ya des
éléments de langage qui commencent à
sortir que j'ai entendu dans la bouche
de dia et voir que j'entendais hier dans
la voix de stanislas guérini bon bref on
sent très bien tout ça en train de se
préparer quand même et qu' ils vont pas
arriver du jour au lendemain sans sans
programme donc un projet est en train de
s'écrire une de toute façon il n'y a pas
de grande surprise sur la trajectoire
politique économique sociale des menus
le maquereau on sait bien quelles sont
ses grandes priorités donc il y aura pas
énormément de surprises mais je
maintiens quand même que le danger pour
lui c'est l'erreur de là l'erreur de
parcours la faute de langage la faute de
propos de la proposition quand il sera
officiellement candidat mais oui l
erreur peut-être aussi d'avoir cette
tentation d'enjamber en quelque sorte le
scrutin de de faire apparaître sa
réélection comme c'est tellement
tellement naturel que voilà un accident
effectivement ou un mauvais mot un
événement peut avoir une forte incidence
sur sa propre candidature et les
français peuvent lui en vouloir de voler
un petit peu cette campagne électorale
puisque les oppositions 10 bay a pas de
débat puisque on débat face au principal
concurrence ça peut agacer ça peut
agacer fortement ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que plus il se déclare tard
effectivement moins et l'attend pour
défendre d'un nouveau projet une
nouvelle vision et plus ça indique aussi
qu'il faudra certainement une campagne
sur la stabilité sur voilà la
reconduction sur la stabilité et la
continuité en fait de ce qu'il a déjà
commencé à initier et de dire voilà j'ai
eu un quinquennat ponctuées de crises je
n'ai pas pu aller au bout des choses on
pense bien sûr à la réforme des
retraites
outre et donc ça peut être aussi un
élément de son discours a minima avec
une campagne courte oui c'est
intéressant votre question parce qu on a
le sentiment quand même qui se joue
aussi en ce moment les germes d'une
crise qui vient peut-être emmanuel
macron va-t-il être réélu sans trop de
difficulté d'autant plus s'il est réel
si les face à marine le pen je pense que
son obsession ça ne pas avoir baladé
pécresse en face de lui mais on sent les
dans la société les germes d'une crise
qui vient quand je dis ça c'est que on a
eu les juges on sent bien que tout vu de
la braise n'est pas totalement éteintes
on a vu la tentative du fameux convoi de
la liberté d'essayer d'instaurer un
mouvement on voit bien quand même que la
question des salaires avec la
mobilisation la ratp et vendredi dernier
on voit bien que quand même il ya
quelque chose qui qui se passe du côté
du sentiment des français qu'ils sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat sur la
question de la hausse des prix est
absolument attendu est hélas si emmanuel
macron film bénéficie de deux chiffres
économiques de croissance de chômage
plutôt
favorable même si évidemment folie
rentrée entre les lignes on sait que
2020 de risque d'être assez compliqué
sur l'inflation sur la question de
l'inflation sur la question du chômage
aussi 2022 la fin 2009 pourrait être
assez catastrophique sion pour le pôle à
l'évolution de la grille du chômage mais
aussi sur la baisse la fermeture
possible d'un syndrome d'entreprise avec
la fin des des aides de l'état et
remboursement des prêts des garanties
nous les des prêts garantis par l'état
et que donc la situation économique
pourrait favoriser après l'élection
présidentielle le passage des
législatives une crise sociale
importante donc c'est ça qui est assez
intéressant c'est qu'on a le sentiment
que possiblement il ya une partie de
l'électorat français qui ne va pas aller
voter mais qui va penser que l'élection
lui a été volé mathilde ans c'est ce qui
est prévu pour la déclaration de
candidature ou c'est le flou total dans
la majorité avec ce qui se passe en
ukraine même le chef de l'état ne s'est
pas les et travaille sur plusieurs
options mais qui sont bien sûr
secrètement gardés et surtout compte
tenu du contexte
n'est pas exclu que la tonalité la forme
évolue compte tenu du contexte
géopolitique et de la détention qui
existent aux frontières de l'europe
[Musique]